for three decades the child allocation  Bureau has combatted catastrophic  overpopulation this sibling will be  processed under authority of the child  allocation Act to build a sustainable  future full of hope and possibility how  do you plan on hiding this starting  tomorrow you will each get to go outside  on the day of the week that is your name  Sunday will get to go outside on Sunday  Monday on Monday Tuesday on Tuesday and  so on you will all take on the singular  identity of Karen second Tara knew your  own siblings no seven siblings surviving  to adulthood you destroy my credibility  mix ethnic step into the van swing when  there's not showing to please gonna go  out there where am I going  run the trash was often the impact  sorry  what happens to one of you  happens to you all  you